[Music]  let me explain our student debt  forgiveness program to all of you you  the good people who are having your  loans forgiven you people who paid your  loans or never got them in the first  place and then you people who never even  went to college we're forgiving up to 20  grand of your student loan debt yeah  because we're awesome do not forget  about us in november okay i know you're  mad remember this is targeted relief for  working class people like a married  couple making 240 grand a year you don't  want them to suffer do you um  let me get back to you later are you  willing to donate just seven dollars to  help us win in november we gotta keep  making progress who knows maybe cancel  more debt down the road huh  no we can't stop subsidizing student  loans harvard's endowment is only 50  billion dollars you don't want harvard  to suffer do you oh please you couldn't  even spell moral hazard  [Music]